hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
Kerbal space program okay if you know me
you know that I've been playing this in
the off time outside of the let's play
I've got about 15 hours total clocked in
so have I made any progress well you
know me so no the answer is no but
anyway I do have a probe in space and
I've been trying to get a space station
up and operational so let's see if this
launches I don't remember if this design
worked at all oh let's find out let's
see what happens cuz I mean I'll be
what's the worst could happen I've blown
up so many kerbals I don't even
understand why they trust me anymore but
whatever whatever man alright seems
stable see do I even have an SAS module
on here I don't know we're gonna find
out oh it's oh it's jiggling oh it's
chilling oh that's not good that's not
good okay wait wait wait what we're
doing okay we're doing okay just need to
tone it back cuz these engines are gonna
overheat and besides you don't need to
go that fast in the lower atmosphere
anyway because there's a limit to how
fast you can go because there's more air
to push through closer to the surface as
there would be up above the clouds and
especially in the sky space area you
know the thing above the clouds that
I've rarely seen but anyway so you just
need to take it nice and gentle and
really relaxed I remember I remember
this now it was like really really
wibbly-wobbly and I had no idea of what
to do about I think if I like connected
stretch to there maybe it might help but
I have no idea so
yeah we're just gonna ride this one out
see if we can't get this sumbitch into
space okay turning off the SAS which is
probably a dumb idea oh god oh god oh
god
turn it back on I just need to get in an
angular trajectory so that I can get up
into space but we're still wibbly-wobbly
although no no we're it's pretty bad but
now we are accelerating to our maximum
speed oculus this is scientific terms if
you know if you don't know I'm a
biomedical engineer so I know what I've
talked about half the time let's see if
that'll prove good for anything okay
somehow I gotta ok secondary engines
engaged unknown detaching we're
spreading the spinning is not good to
take away the spin okay just go well SAS
is off I'm on full manual oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god that's up
need to not be up need to be pointed
other way no no no no get back to that
yellow get back to the yellow turn it
off [ __ ] I'm spinning I got it I got it
I got it I got it I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got it
turn SAS off damn it down don't dump
dump dump dump dump dump da nailed it
hahaha yeah yeah I did it I did it I'm
going up to a huge engines yes
everybody somehow that didn't explode
yeah hey good job everybody give
yourselves a round of applause for all
that you've done anyway you can see I've
got a zmapp satellite and some debris in
orbit I had a lot more debris before but
I'm not worried about that
I need to get up to a regular clip here
so that I can get to the proper
trajectory in order to readjust myself
into a more appropriate trajectory for a
retrograde burn retrograde
okay good enough now just go a little
bit further and now turn just a little
bit to the right a little bit to the
right turn off si yes okay thank you
and then si s already engage engage the
engines warp factor five I don't know
what I'm doing with this I'm gonna put
it into orbit and try to release the
space station as its own module because
the space station has no engines on it
which is probably not smart it probably
should have had at least some sort of an
engine type device on him but as you can
see right now I've got plenty of fuel so
I probably don't need to detach it once
I get to that point right now I'm just
burning retrograde so that I've
increased the perio stasis to get it
into a nice circular orbit but as you
can see we're not quite lined up we're
gonna have to fix that somehow I don't
know how to fix that one this one's just
gonna be quietly off-kilter
the other one's pretty okay not great
actually this one is more close to the
moon's orbit than anything so that's
actually probably pretty fine okay we're
gonna go to about a 300 thousand meter
orbit or 300 kilometer orbit and then
see what we can do from there yup yup
come on where's that other side I'm
burning fuel here I shouldn't take this
long it usually goes faster ascension
must not be for air it is okay that
needs to get up to about 300 oh that's C
you're in orbit I very rarely hear that
congratulations markiplier thank you
computer nurse and shut up I know what's
best
I'm an astronaut okay I need to UM Oh
nike's I need to get over to the other
side and then increase the perio saw saw
saw saw saw the perio sauce until I can
get this into a above six hundred
thousand meter orbit
or that's what I'm gonna try to do
anyway let's see how that works out
usually my plans don't go this well so
I'm actually quite surprised okay in all
seriousness this is quite an involved
thing so if if you if you go into this
you can go into it expecting one of the
one of the most amazing space whole
space program simulators that you'll
ever find in a game it's it's pretty
incredible how in-depth this is I mean
on its cartoony exterior there's a ton
of stuff that needs to that can be done
and needs to be learned I mean there's
this guy Scott Manley that I've watched
some of his videos on YouTube
he's like a rocket scientist basically
and he does calculations he's got a
reusable moon base that mines something
like some valuable materials and he's
just like crazy in depth with his
knowledge into this and if you're
looking for a like a good let's play
that does more important stuff than what
I'm doing here then that's probably what
you're gonna be looking for okay we're
in generally where roughly 600,000 meter
orbit plus or minus about 15 so if you
see whoa look at me go as you can see
our space station is now orbiting and it
has just a little bit of fuel left where
is it it's in the darkness let's go over
to the sunny side Boosh stop thank you
okay now you can see that we're floating
high above the earth in perfect well
perfect circular orbit now this is the
docking port on this space station
there's a life capsule heal on the main
thing with Fred my Fred me and Dan's are
Kerman these two brave souls here who
trusted me with their lives are here and
they can let's just take one out on evey
a for a second here just for a second
you see he is currently holding on to
the ladder system which is very
intelligently placed here so I'm gonna
make him go into the crew hatch and so
you can see that he is now in the crew
area so he doesn't need to be in that
stasis that capsule anymore now the
other thing that I need is um hey I
forget I don't really know how to extend
the
the solar panels I'm pretty sure that's
important to the whole life-sustaining
thing so I'm gonna have Danzer in the
command module and I don't know where
Fred me when Fred me needs some private
time in the crew quarters if you know
what I mean it's about a long flight
alright so anyway I'm gonna leave this
sit so I'll wait hang on let me show you
gonna as you can see I've got my space
station core orbiting at 600,000 that's
probably pretty high for a space station
cuz it's gonna be harder to get other
things that far up it's just making it a
little harder for myself but whatever I
do what I can with best I can so I've
gotten a satellite here that's going
quite fast Space Station going quite
fast
we're actually 32 have a space thing ok
my next thing though is I'm gonna get
one that I'm gonna get a sumbitch to the
moon I'm gonna get something to the moon
toilet mode and actually what I'm gonna
do is I'm not gonna use that I'm gonna
use I've learned quite a bit since the
last one so you guys can basically
criticize as you will but you will see
that I am too Pro to be a sways by this
actually I'm not even gonna worry about
landing I'm just putting that for
aerodynamics sake I don't expect my
courage to survive this by the by just
throwing that out there they are doomed
they are so screwed
it's not even funny but it is ok so
basically what I need is I need to make
this in multiple stages this is the last
stage it's a really fuel-efficient stage
trying it it's got the poodle engine on
it and we're gonna have some things that
are gonna blow here we're gonna go for a
long long ship so we're gonna have a lot
of different high-powered stages and
then some low powered ones so this will
be the high power no no not that high
powered
uh-uh my brains not working here I guess
I guess that could be no that wouldn't
work though and needs it needs a more
powerful Devon I don't I need some more
no that's plenty powerful yeah that's
why yeah that's fine what am I talking
about that's it's a big engine it needs
to needs to be able to do that okay so
we got we got that we're gonna do this
in a bunch of stages totally reckless I
bet all of you professional Kerbal space
program is out there are like rolling
your heads like oh oh my god there's a
horrible anyway so I'm gonna ignore your
criticism for now because I I know what
I do I know what I am do and I am do
good I am do real good okay so this is
in a bunch of different configurations
here so to get this off the ground this
is this is all for the final stages but
to get this off the ground it needs some
serious grunt power because smaller
engines ain't gonna cut it because this
thing is heavy so we're gonna have a
triple order of rock Oh max jumbo fuel
tanks but first we need our radial D
couplers here to get them a little bit
of space off of a the main body there
and yes this will hold I know it'll hold
I've held it before it you son of a
[ __ ] there we go yes they'll hold just
fine don't worry about it I know what
I'm doing I know what's best you all
calm your tips
all right I can hear you all yelling at
me like are you doing it's so stupid
don't do Bismark apart what are you even
thinking can you understand that's gonna
be all my guy you're so dumb no I'm not
sure you're always trying to criticize
okay anyway enough of that I'm trying to
be somewhat serious here so what's gonna
happen is I'm going to put a lot of
reinforcement on this because like with
the last one because these are so big
and like girthy there's gonna be a lot
of shakin and shimmying going on and we
do not need shakes we do not need
excessive shaking going on in my rocket
I am the commander of this mission well
not really I'm
kind of the commander but I will not
have shakes and/or shimmies anywhere
near this base of operation in fact I
think I'm gonna ban dancing we wasn't
that done already I don't know but
anyway we got our aerodynamic
son-of-a-bitch here so three primaries
oh wait I need more control
I need launch stability enhancers thank
you okay launching the first student
actually do this more intelligently you
launch the engine first and then release
the clamps and that kind of makes it a
little bit better okay and then activate
the second engine before you release the
other ones that way you can get maintain
more momentum I'll release the other one
fire really see last one fire and we're
good okay save this sumbitch we're going
to the moon baby we're going to the moon
we're going to the moon yeah go to the
moon yeah going to the moon to the moon
or anyway yeah warp ahead till it's day
thank you
daytime they say yes on why are you
shaking so much you son of a [ __ ] fired
and it's tow it's so beautiful
he's so majestic it's like a bird it's
gorgeous it's operating but it's
beautiful nonetheless right making
progress as you can see this sumbitch is
pretty heavy I probably could have done
four rockets and that might actually
worked out a little better because this
primary stage is only gonna last so
maybe about thirty thousand feet I'm
guessing by anyway well we'll worry
about this the predict you the
particulars of it later it's carrying
about I don't know two extra well one
and a half extra of these orange ones
without actually don't you dig couple
not yet you son of a [ __ ] all right we
can slow down quite a bit here save some
fuel until we get out of the initial
atmosphere
I forget the technical names for the
atmosphere but there's like the
stratosphere is way up and then there's
the hemisphere no there's a perennial
sphere and then the
the Markus fear I'm pretty sure is one
of them or if it's not I will name it
the kirbo sphere see we're almost out of
fuel now and we're barely up there but
luckily we've got more than the last
stage because that's why we're really
okay we hit 10,000 so let's get in our
angular orbit here this whole thing is
pretty stable
I mean besides some shakes and shimmies
it's it's doing a pretty good job I mean
those those those engines don't look
great but I mean they're holding up okay
all right let's kick it up a notch and
then crank the other one out so that we
can have this ready to rock all right
those are empty
boom get rid of them we got a spin
counteract a spin cool down that engine
okay we got a spin let's get back into
our correct trajectory we're it's a
little too far over ha ha hey hey hey
stop being a dick why what the hell
you're not supposed to go into a spin I
turn SAS on and then you start spinning
Turtles up with that get get get get get
get get get get get get get get get get
get get get you son of a [ __ ] I will oh
my god I will Jack slap you until the
break of dawn and you won't even know
what dawn is in space so oh why are you
spinning when the SAS is on SAS what are
you doing at whoa wait a minute wait a
minute
it's correcting it's correcting it's
correcting it's correcting
dude enough all right I guess that'll do
all right it's going you know it's going
in a pretty good direction I mean if
it's rotating it doesn't really mean all
that much okay let's see how we're doing
here
our a Paul stasis is pretty darn good so
we can cut the engines and then warp up
to meet our maker and then we will warp
up into maximum and that's will be what
we are looking for scooch scooch herbage
scooter beat you over there scooch it
scooch it scoot your rocket boot over
there get over there
get get get get get get and Aragon bring
up adder map don't go crazy on me you
son of a [ __ ] I'm maneuvering you you
need to go very very steady all right
all right that's a little down done up
well don't overshoot it Oh
we're now into Swedish kerbals yeah yes
they stopped top top top okay stop stop
stop stop
whatever good enough go for it ban go
for it boys pump it
whoa look at that thing grow got so big
and round anything above 70,000 meters
is space by the way you're out of the
atmosphere you don't have to worry about
dragging you I'm out of fuel I need to
break off the stage finish fire here we
are that's better that's why we have
more than one stage so we can make all
the way to moon and these last engines
are fairly powerful but they are super
efficient see how much fuel I am using
in comparison to before when I was using
much fuel but now I am super efficient
it should be enough to make the moon and
we are increasing our trajectory pretty
good way I am talking like this I don't
know don't question me I know what is
best
any minute now there we go
we did a little swap er Rooney so we're
continuing to grow the a post ASIS but
we're getting a bit far from the Paris
periapsis so eventually pretty soon here
we're gonna need to swing around to the
other side actually we think here
actually no we should be good we should
be able to will should be able to
actually hang on I got a plan what am I
doing here I'm not even planning my my
route to the to the Mun
okay um I think I'm gonna need to circle
around to the other side for this --n
whoa okay good I'm pretty sure that I'm
gonna need to increase it from here and
then I'll be able to I'll be able to get
it I'm just this is total guesswork by
the way I don't I really do not know
what I need to do III know about how
setting maneuvers but you know I can set
the manoeuvre that doesn't mean that I
know what I what what I need to do or
what it's telling me to do so it's all
just blind luck from here there we go
all right what do all right now we get
closer to the appo stasis here it'll be
closer little bit closer we seem to be
off kilter though but get off kilter you
stupid SAS you're such a son of a [ __ ]
okay that's good enough
pop it racket unfortunately you can't
accelerate while you're thrusting in
space which probably good thing because
the acceleration mechanics in this game
are not working when you accelerate when
you're launching it pretty much
guarantees your whole thing is going to
explode no matter what you do okay we're
pumping weed pampinea tip let's hope we
don't hit our space station or satellite
at all but we're going to the moon it's
gonna take a while by the by good thing
we got a lot of fuel seriously this is
gonna take a while gotta get this all
the way out basically what we're doing
when we burn like this you go around in
space it you kind of use the planet as a
slingshot I think it would have been
better or I might have been I needed to
be smarter about it you you're supposed
to like die
closer to the planet and then go out but
I mean this is working I guess it's
gonna get there eventually it's gonna
get there and then we're gonna crash
into the moon
I'll wait the moon Oh pass ah
oh I thought oh never mind I'm gonna
have to wait four stops out top top top
top now now good enough okay so now we
just accelerate until well basically we
gotta wait until the moon wraps around
cuz I don't know why for some stupid
reason I really thought that the moon
orbited the other way and we're now we
miss it son of a [ __ ] just get over we
got I accidentally accelerated too fast
and on that last approach we got caught
in the moon and then we slung shot out
of the moon and now we are oh it's too
late now so we are in orbit around the
Sun good good job everybody
we're now my vacation oh the good that's
Kerbal I hope for a second I thought my
space station was some house what like
just shooting off into space but well we
might incident with do not at some point
so I guess I could try to land on crash
land on Doudna but I mean it would take
a long time to get that approach so for
now I guess that'll do it so sorry this
went horribly wrong I don't know what he
did well I know what I did but I'm not
gonna blame myself
nurse damn it you're supposed to tell me
what to do okay alright so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation
I've done and as always I will see you